what we do here just go back back
[Music]
and all their own little things but
these map updates they're just they're
just so good they blow my puny little
mind hello there and welcome to
Playstation grenade season X has arrived
and with it comes a metric ton of map
changes from the obvious to the secret
from the Wow to the always oh is that it
oh okay
this is season x is taking us through
time so expect ridiculous changes
throughout the entire season like Tilted
becoming the wild wild west
yeah it's potentially true if you're new
around these parts and you didn't know
I'm trying my best to get to 1 million
subscribers and in return I'll reveal my
fog Lea face to you to give you
nightmares sounds like a good deal right
anyway let's get on with this season 10
week 1 let's do this where do we start
how about the biggest thing possible Hut
watch
no I'm kidding we'll start with the
big-ass meteor suspended in the ether
yes indeedy-do dusty depo is back in all
its glory
and yes I do say depo not deep Oh so
let's agree to disagree and still get
along yeah the real word is French so we
all should really be saying deep ooh
Deepu because of that language barrier
my friends and I began to call this area
dusty Deadpool's don't know why I told
you that completely pointless
so back in season 4 the meteor hit the
island and turned dusty depot into dusty
divot but now that time is relative we
are currently living a millisecond from
disaster as the meteor just sort of sits
there waiting so if the asteroid never
hit us then the visitor never visited
and the Rockets never flew and the cool
nod to that storyline is buried inside
that floating rock no no that than the
visitors chamber that's damn cool do you
remember season 4 tried to figure out
what was inside those were the good old
days
not only is dusty back all original and
og but so too are the factories
personally one of my favorite landing
spots in season 1 mainly because it was
usually empty but judging by how many
people keep saying that they love that
place this place is gonna be stacked
this season so we'll probably avoid it
nearby also returns the small
containers which made me remember about
my awesome building skills back in
season 2 check this out
unlike a turbocharged snail
oh don't dab sorry I didn't know I was
good at rush still am nearby the new
dusty no nearby the new older dusty now
the remains of the monster from season 9
the destroyer of worlds still has the
sword through his skull but the land
nearby is beginning to flourish new
plant life springing up constantly this
looks important for the future so let's
check back here next week the incident
which caused all this time bending
shenanigans the orb at loot lake has
unleashed an antigravity field a zone to
frolic around in once again I don't
expect this to stay for very long so
now's the time to relive your
anti-gravity days from when Kevin the
cube made those weird lifts on the floor
oh and speaking of Kevin how do you
think he'll return he has two dozen T
I'd love to know your thoughts so chuck
them below I have a feeling that the
power supplier Tilted is going to cause
a blackout and revert to another time
period
yeehaw monkey fluffers the wild world
wiki Wild West remember old man
truckasaurus just above the track well
in the old G fortnight days he was frail
he had a walking stick in hand then in
season 9 he had a major upgrade his
walking stick became a sword
foreshadowing the robots lifting the
sword in the final battle but now here
in season X hang on do we say season X
or season 10 Roman numerals are all
great but we don't call double-oh-seven
oo VII 3 sorry sorry moving on anyway
now in season 10 truckasaurus is a
monument for that final battle repainted
to resemble the Power Ranger style
Voltron character and the sword it's a
loft in victory sadly though his drift
arm is a pile on the ground so tough
break bro in the real fight his arm
dropped into the ocean so remember that
cuz I think it's going to be something
later in the season right now it's time
the one the real fans want hot watch
the greatest story line in Fortnight
history the shack which was destroyed by
Kevin the cube and slowly painstakingly
slowly the rebuild began now in week 1
of season 10 we have one extra piece of
wood I know what you're thinking you're
thinking Wow hallelujah am i right but
what forever before I get into what
candor forever means I'd like to thank
these fine specimens for their support
in season 9 you guys are legends to me
please remember that always if you're
buying things in season 10 please think
about using code a damaru the plan is to
give all this money back in giveaways at
the moment we have community meetups
over on Twitch so you're welcome to join
and win some goodies anyway let's move
on thanks again now it's time for a sad
one the stone family I cannot find them
anywhere season eights are rock the
Dwayne Johnson and Sharon Stone begin
courting and that instant love resulted
in unprotected sax and Kid Rock was born
he went out into the world last season
only to be moments from death on a cliff
edge luckily pebbles the rock viola yeah
came to his rescue
but now they've all gone that extra dog
is still there sniffing a toilet but I
don't think he's supposed to be there
but saying that we all know someone who
likes to smell toilets don't we that was
weird
so where will they reappear let me know
your thoughts okay
here's a cool change which will take
weeks to come to fruition just by the
Elan musk face north of the stone family
plot is this monstrosity can you tell
what's happening here yes indeed risky
reals is coming back at the moment it's
just a sofa on the screen but you mark
my words in six weeks this will be the
home of movies movie night is coming to
fortnight maybe another creative video
competition is on the way I do hope so
over to tilted towers or neo tilted as
it's now called last season did you
notice the building site which never
really changed well this season that is
a thing of the past the first steps the
baby steps towards a new building is in
place yeah it's super subtle but it is
there
we'll do our usual thing and keep coming
back each week to witness the erection
of a building you're so dirty minded you
need to stop that there is still more
let's go south to West world for the
last few seasons I've been besotted by a
house which every week had more chairs
added to it it was so strange we'll
check it out this season shut the front
door the chair house has a rival this is
the TV house random guesses needed what
the heck is this for a challenge
probably or something bigger we shall
see just north of West world is
something very sinister get your
eyeballs round this a small building out
in the wilderness with suspicious
tentacle like roots protruding I've
looked around I've racked my brains I
cannot figure this out to save my life I
am dumbfounded any help would be greatly
appreciated what could this monstrosity
be oh and one more before we finish back
in the olden days when flush Factory
wasn't crushed just up the road from it
was a chair a simple oversized chair
that became a sleigh when Christmas
rolled round and when singularity popped
up last season it changed again into a
spaceship have you been back this season
in season 10 it's a chair again
ain't that right lovely let's do some
more updates which are so random yet so
fantastic down in the snowy south it
looks like flush Factory may be about to
make a comeback or rather a splash back
yeah I write my own jokes
check out these oversized toilets and
look what's inside too there's also a
giant teddy bear stuck in a shack just
as the desert biome begins and that
crashed battle bus we've had since
fought nightmares that has now gone
a lazy link sign has suddenly appeared
over in lazy lagoon fingers crossed we
get the Golf Course back and there's a
gnome army building just to the west of
pleasant park this is nice
fuel oh and one last thing the pleasant
park sign has been updated whoa have we
done it I think we have are the little
things I noticed were the island-wide
air streams have been taken out and the
geezers have stopped doing their thing
so I'm expecting that
Easter Island heads to reappear next
week hopefully with rifts too cuz I
bloody love those things please let me
know if you see any other changes we
have a disc garden if you'd like to
contribute to it it would be much
appreciated we have lots of cool people
most of them are cool people some of
them are just weird just really weird
but family isn't firmly bragger I'm
going I haven't slept for 43 hours so
I'm off to bed now I'll be streaming
again this weekend if you want to jump
in for some community shenanigans I'll
be giving away more bustled passes for
those who don't have them yet anyway
it's been emotional I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
see you next time
[Music]